hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
president biden renewing calls for
bipartisanship during his first address
to a joint session of congress
but a number of republican lawmakers are
skeptical arguing the democratic agenda
will further divide
americans gop congresswoman ashley
hinson of iowa weighs in
on the possibility of her party working
with the biden administration on
infrastructure immigration
and voting rights legislation and
president biden unveiling a 1.8 trillion
dollar american family's plan which aims
to invest
in child care and medical leave programs
associate editor of the wall street
journal
john bussey shares his insight on the
administration's economic policies
and what may lie ahead as the nation
comes out of the pandemic
plus commentary from fox news political
analyst gianno caldwell
the fox news rundown is a daily news
podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe on
your
favorite podcast player by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
i'm dana perrino i'm juan williams i'm
kennedy and this
is the fox news rundown
friday april 30th 2021 i'm chris foster
president biden's american families plan
includes money for things like free
pre-k and community college
iowa house republican ashley henson says
though nothing's ever free my
eight-year-old was in the car with me
just a few weeks ago
listening to one of those radio
advertisements where they're like free
this free that
he turned to me he's eight and he says
mom nothing's free right
so i think it's not lost on people that
somebody is caught footing that bill
and it's going to be the taxpayers of
this country i'm lisa brady
america appears to be on a re-opening
role
so is the country ready to buy what the
president
is selling it's not too hard of a sell
to the broader american people when
they aren't generally affected by those
tax increases you know you talk about
taxing the wealthy and that seems to go
over pretty well
with people and i'm gianno caldwell i've
got the final word
on the fox news rundown
president biden followed up his speech
to congress wednesday night with a rally
in georgia
trying to keep the momentum going for
his legislative agenda house speaker
nancy pelosi says americans should get
behind it
the bold investments of the american
jobs plan the americans family plan
invest in the foundations of our
strengths
families workers in the middle class the
jobs plan is the largest plan
since world war ii and the family's plan
will make historic differences for
families
senate republican leader mitch mcconnell
calls the president's plans
a blueprint for giving washington even
more money
and even more power to micromanage
american families and build the
countries
liberal elites want instead of the
future
americans want iowa house republican
ashley hinson agrees
it was the heavy hand of expanding
government programs expanding government
spending
on the backs of taxpayers of this
country she was there during the
president's joint address to congress
i wanted to hear him lay out solutions
to the challenges facing iowa families
our farmers in this in this country and
our small businesses
but i heard no plans to rein in wasteful
spending on out-of-touch priorities to
respect
taxpayers i heard no plan to help secure
our border to keep iowa families safe
and i didn't hear a real plan to
prioritize the needs of rural america
that have long been overlooked by
coastal elites here in washington dc so
the speech missed the mark for me again
um a lot of free stuff and a lot of
fluff in president biden's address
yeah i mean you were in the chamber
during the speech one of the relatively
few members who were there because of
coronavirus restrictions and people home
in their district it was an off week
uh you said going in that you were going
to be listening for areas of agreement
you had an open mind didn't hear
anything
uh you know there were some areas where
i looked at like world broadband for
example that's a place where i think
that there is shared consensus on
helping to work towards solutions to
provide that last mile fiber for example
iowa learned firsthand as a very rural
state how important
access to that internet is not only for
um you know for school and for work but
also for healthcare and for
agriculture so that's an area that i
think we can work together
i would love to come to the table and
work on infrastructure i met with the
button administration's legislative
liaison a few weeks ago
to express my you know my ideas for
focusing on roads and bridges
and locks and dams broadband is a part
of that conversation
but i think their plan is out of touch
when they're talking about spending more
on electric vehicle subsidies
than they are on actual physical
infrastructure like locks and dams and
roads and bridges
yeah i mean obviously the administration
is expanding the definition of
infrastructure here saying look it's
anything that helps america work and
that includes child care
for example now is there any talk among
your colleagues about like look how do
you
politically fight free help for my
family
you know who's paying for it is an
abstract concept
for a lot of people who are struggling
to pay for child care for example
well so i'm trying to focus on the root
causes for why child care is so
expensive
why access is so hard to come by so i'm
trying to do that from the process
standpoint we've over regulated a lot of
these businesses to the point where
um it is expensive to conduct business
so i'm on a fact-finding mission the
legislation i've introduced in in
congress is
is on track to find some of those
answers and come up with solutions
but let's be honest here nothing's ever
free my eight-year-old was in the car
with me just a few weeks ago listening
to one of those radio advertisements
where they're like free this free that
he turned to me he's eight and he says
mom nothing's free right
so i think it's not lost on people that
somebody is caught footing that bill
and it's going to be the taxpayers of
this country and when you look at
that plant 1.8 trillion dollars on top
of 1.9 trillion dollars on top of
trillions and trillions of other dollars
of proposed and actual spending
we're going to be above 10 trillion
dollars in spending in just about a year
which um
is is to me a crisis um and we need to
be focusing on respecting taxpayers and
reining in
out of control government this is your
first term so i assume this is your
first presidential address to congress
right
correct yes it is you know watching it
on tv or listening to it you didn't get
that raucous feeling that you usually
get during these did it feel subdued in
the room notwithstanding the president's
you know style anyway it was definitely
a different feeling from what
others had described to me that that
event would have been like i had
basically an entire road to myself
as a new member i kind of expected to be
up in the balcony but i was on the floor
of the house
so i was struck by the fact that you had
you know seasoned senators
sitting up in the balcony of the house
chamber i was on the floor
with many other of my colleagues but um
you know there were so many empty seats
when normally
i know the chamber would be filled to
the brim with not only members of
congress but
you know the full supreme court for
example full cabinet and guest of the
administration and
um we just didn't see that so i think
the mood in the chamber was very
different
um and and you know to be frank we're
all wearing masks
facial expressions are different the the
environment was just very different from
what i was anticipating it would be like
yeah um your team set up a website
called gradebiden.com
to get reaction to the speech and of
course you know get some contact
information for fundraising i noticed
the f
grade was very helpfully the default
filled in already
uh have you checked what the final grade
on the site was
well we've had a majority of upgrades
and i don't think that's surprising but
um we are encouraging people to go to
gradebiden.com and give us their
perspective
i think it's important to hear where
where our constituents agree with the
president and also where they think we
need to be holding the administration
accountable
sharing stories is the number one reason
why i ran for this job i think it's
really important that we're telling
iowan stories at the table and so that's
what my intent is with um
with that website we want the real world
feedback so that we can hold
the administration accountable and come
to the table with some other ideas as
well
i wonder if there's room for compromise
on immigration i know you took a trip to
the border not
too long back are talks progressing
there at all
well unfortunately i think the first
step needs to be actually addressing the
crisis at our border before we have that
conversation about
immigration reform i want to come to the
table on visa reform i actually
i had my staff pull a list for me of all
of the different visa programs that we
have
for for guest workers for example and
for immigrants to this country
i think there's a lot of room there for
improvement in terms of of how we
execute that process but
unfortunately right now we've just got
an open border situation going on and
that's directly due to president biden's
policies he reversed
uh the remaining mexico policy title 42
so he's in essence opened our border
putting our
safety and security at risk not only in
this country but every state
a border state right now and i think
that that needs to be solved first we
have a humanitarian issue and a safety
and security issue at the border
do you have enough workers for this
summer and in your state well it's funny
that you bring that up i had two
zooms already with uh constituents in my
district and the number one issue i keep
hearing about is that
um they can't get people to come to work
uh the federal government is paying
people to come to stay
home right now and so in essence the
private sector is having to compete with
the public sector for work
that's not how we get our economy back
up and roaring that's not how we get
life back to normal in this country
and unfortunately that's that's what
we're seeing every business seems to
have a help wanted sign
another thing that they brought up to me
specifically on these meetings just
today was
you know they heard the president's
message on a 15 minimum wage
that would just kill small businesses in
iowa
so you combine that with potential tax
increases
and it's a one-two punch that most
businesses would not be able to bear
well i've had this conversation before
with uh with
some of your colleagues about a federal
minimum wage 15
uh probably just fine maybe even a
little low in some parts of the country
but
where you are it might be untenable for
some small business owners how about the
idea of a sliding scale like they do
with the
the with federal workers pay and i think
that's
absolutely something we should be
looking at because it does not cost as
much
to live in a state like iowa as it does
to live in california or new york for
example so
that's where i think one size fits all
policies from the federal government are
not the right idea
again that's the message i heard from
the president that he believes more
government is the answer
i think being flexible and coming up
with some of these solutions that
respect states respect that things are
different across the country
are truly important and and actually the
responsible way to govern
and so i look forward to coming to the
table on those discussions but
like i said a 15 minimum wage is not the
answer for iowa
a new fox poll shows 22 percent of
americans more republicans than
democrats
have no plans to be vaccinated for
coronavirus iowa has a fairly high
vaccination rate but it's still top 10
in terms of infections
we're hearing that more and more people
are choosing to be vaccinated
i know in iowa we actually had several
of our counties actually have to say we
don't need any more vaccine because
we've we've got plenty of supply for
the demand that we have right now so i
think we've had quite a
surge in people who have been vaccinated
but i'm encouraging anyone who hasn't
to to do so i think it's the way we get
back to normal if people feel
comfortable doing so i don't want a
mandate for a vaccine but
i myself got my first dose about two
weeks ago and i get my next dose next
tuesday
i'm excited to get life back to normal
and i i see the vaccine as something
important to doing that
i do want to point out as well though as
i listen to that speech i'm talking
about
uh the increased number of americans who
are being vaccinated i do think that's
important and i think that's something
to celebrate
but i didn't hear president biden give
president trump and the administration
before
any credit for what happened and that
actually really bothered me because
operation warp speed uh we wouldn't be
where we we are today without that
and we wouldn't have as many people
vaccinated as we do without that
so um i thought that was a little bit
misleading to the american public
on a personal note you might want to
chug a ton of water the day before and
the day of you get that second shot
uh i've found it it's held out uh and uh
congresswoman it struck me when i found
out you were coming on
finally that as common a name as ashley
was when you and i were growing up i
couldn't think of any
in congress so i looked it up i found
one other and he was a guy
ashley b wright he was a republican from
massachusetts he died in office in 1897
so you are in fact the first ever female
ashley in congress so for what it's
worth congratulations right
well i i feel honored to be the first uh
ashley henson
uh woman in congress but i think what's
interesting is um
you know obviously ashley was a common
name in the early 80s for
for young women but it was historically
before
um a man's name um i think a famous
character obviously in
uh gone with the wind was named ashley
so and it was man so
um i i think that uh what i would bring
to the table is that uh
or my husband likes to say there's only
one ashley henson for sure and i think
he's right on that
congresswoman from iowa republican
ashley henson uh
congressman thanks a lot for coming on
the rundown thanks so much for having me
this is giano caldwell with your fox
news commentary
coming up president biden's sweeping
spending plans are giving new fuel to
some
long simmering debates about big
government
for instance it's time to remember that
we the people are the government
you and i not some force in a distant
capital
he says we need to prove democracy still
works
and while republicans slam his proposed
tax hikes
my fellow americans trickle down
trickle down economics has never worked
and it's time to grow the economy from
the bottom in the middle
out he says he's proposing tax reform
the taxes that he's talking about
increasing uh
are on business which after all had a
tax decrease from 35 percent all the way
down to 21
uh in 2017. john bussey is associate
editor of the wall street journal
and a fox news contributor and he's
talking about bringing that up about
halfway
back up to 28 not up to the original 35
and then he's going to
raise some taxes on uh the wealthy folks
who make uh over four hundred thousand
uh 400
400 000 a year in income so you know
it's not
it's not too hard of a sell to the
broader american people when
they aren't generally affected by those
tax increases you know you talk about
taxing the wealthy and that seems to go
over pretty well
with people and what he's what he's
talking about spending the money on
is really aimed at uh sort of lower
income and middle income households i
mean he's making this point that
where's that money going to go it's
going to go into programs designed
to help those individuals um
including with kind of build out of
infrastructure not just roads and
in bridges but infrastructure that
he feels we should we should view as
infrastructure
like uh caregiving programs for
uh kids uh and for the elderly uh why
would that be infrastructure well
if you do that then you free up
a large chunk of potential employees
a lot of them women who are otherwise
stuck at home giving
giving care and so it's a kind of it's a
very raucous
capitalist thing to do you you provide
some alternative to that
and you present to the labor force
a whole bunch more inputs and that's
good for business because they have that
much more talent to call on
a couple of criticisms that we hear
about these plans in general
one would be that it doesn't exactly add
up
that you won't get enough revenue from
the tax increases to pay for all these
trillions of dollars
and the other thing is that there's like
a built-in argument in his proposals
that the trump tax cuts mainly helped
the wealthy
and added to the deficit is is the jury
still out on that or is it only
republicans who think those tax cuts
were good for the economy
well the the tax cuts particularly for
business uh we found
that a lot of that did not go into
business investment
uh well why is that well in part it may
have been because
corporate ceos looked at the tax cuts
they were very generous
again from 35 percent all the way down
to 21
uh and they thought to themselves you
know is this going to be permanent or
are we going to see a democratic
administration reverse some of this do i
really want to invest this money
in a project a big plant that's going to
take 40 years to amortize
or do i instead want to just buy back my
shares
uh boost the share price of the company
that that benefits
investors and that benefits other
stakeholders
it helps the ceo uh meet his bonus his
own bonus targets
and we saw a lot of that we saw a lot of
in uh investment in
share share buybacks uh so uh you know
the criticism
the criticism uh about uh
this actually having propelled the
economy there's no question that the
economy picked up as a result of
corporate taxes
being lower but we also ran enormous
budget deficits
including a record budget deficit at the
end of the last fiscal year
in october 2020. some of that was driven
by necessary pandemic spending
uh but there were deficits nonetheless
what about the
argument or the concern at least that
the proposed tax increases could drive
companies out of the u.s in to places
where it's cheaper to operate
the president says his plans will create
millions of good-paying jobs that
can't be outsourced is that too good to
be true or will we never know unless it
happens
well companies are very creative uh as
are
individuals whether they be wealthy or
not wealthy on finding ways to get
around taxes and we saw that happening
didn't we
uh that because taxes were higher in
the united states than other places
companies were decamping from the united
states and
reorganizing themselves in places like
ireland uh where the taxes would be
lower they're paying for you know a
service in the united states they're
paying for
a bundle of services everything from the
rule of law to
to national security to good roads to
judges that uh decide arbitration cases
affecting their companies and so they're
going to want to be here they're going
to want to be
in the u.s economy and
raising taxes back up to 28 is still
seven points below where they were they
were at 35 they would be at 28.
that's still pretty attractive to
companies so
that could very well happen you might
see some more of that but there's also
forces both public relations and
financial forces
that would be working to keep those
companies in the united states there was
so much growth for the economy
in the first quarter we now know over
six percent growth
is that making the case on some level
that the economy
would be bouncing back no matter what we
did as we emerge from the pandemic i
mean
how much stimulus is or was really
needed
there are several forces that are coming
to bear on
why that number is so high and mind you
uh the fed is uh it believes that uh and
other economists
the economist in general believe that
that number might actually pick up
further in the second quarter and then
kind of stay
stable through the second half of the
year for a really robust
showing um for for the year the forces
are not just direct stimulus they are
pent up demand uh you had
you had an economy that was kind you
know in one way or another partially
shut down
for most of 2020 um people weren't
buying things they were at home
uh that pent up demand the consumer is
two-thirds of the economy
that pent-up demand is now playing out a
little bit more as some states open up
at least partially
people get vaccinated they feel a little
bit more confident leaving their homes
engaging
in business outside of of the house
and then you have the not just the
direct stimulus that
uh in the in the uh 1.9 billion program
that was
uh approved earlier this year for the
coronavirus
you have the expectation that you're
going to have
a you know 2.3 or something maybe even
you know
less than that probably at the end of
the day on infrastructure spending
uh and this latest spending uh that the
dividend
administration is proposing some of that
is already the expectations for that
those steroid shots
the economy are already playing into
these numbers
and so uh you know
yes there's a little bit of artificial
support for the economy including low
interest rates
uh that the fed has sustained um
and then there's some organic parts of
it which is the consumer coming back
could we be heading for a potential
stumbling block
once the eviction moratoriums are lifted
and foreclosure moratoriums too for that
matter i mean especially if millions
people are still out of work
maybe you need some kind of transition
as they face the full freight of bills
again
but without enough income to cover it
you'll see some pressure i think to
extend those to just
to play it safe to help those people who
are in
that that group that might still not
have a job
and there's a lot of people that still
don't have a job but mind you the
the unemployment rate has dropped from
14.8 uh april 2020
to about six percent now so people are
are finding jobs um what's kind of
mitigating against
uh maybe extending it we'll have to see
what happens
is that rents are beginning to increase
again
uh the housing market in general the buy
the purchase housing market is on a tear
we haven't seen this kind of activity
since
2006 again a lot of pent-up demand
so there may not have to be an extension
one other question related to the the
trillions in spending
that have already happened and the
additional trillions that are being
proposed
republicans certainly raise concern
about the national debt
what's the impact on americans as
individuals though from that or is it
really just a question of whether we're
concerned about
leaving debt to future generations yes
uh josh mitchell and jake schlesinger
have two very good stories
on wsj.com about this there's a
philosophical sea change right now
in the white house and the feeling
uh there is that we have not invested
enough
in the well-being of americans uh and
that
we might run up the debt but it's
critical
for us to do so because it will pay off
with a more vibrant competitive economy
in the future you know some of this
infrastructure spending is a hedge
against china
which outright spends you know
billions and hundreds of billions of of
dollars on
industries and supporting industries uh
we have kind of shied away from
industrial policy in the united states
but you're seeing a little bit more
engagement
uh by this by this president uh perhaps
some basic research funded by the
government
uh in shipbuilding in electric vehicles
in other areas of
the the economy are the the are the
proposals
but it's not the first time that a
president and it's not just democrats
have launched a big infrastructure or
spending program that they believe will
pay off long term
for america by enhancing economic
activity enhancing economic
competitiveness with the country
you know look at you look at eisenhower
and building out the national road
system that was a big infrastructure
project
costs a lot of money and look
at the enormous benefit that that uh
america derived from it
and there'll be arguments on both sides
of this there'll be arguments about the
tax policies too there's
discussion now of raising capital gains
if
if a person dies now they can hand off
their assets to
their family uh and there's a cost basis
step
up that you don't have to pay for all
the capital gains that were accrued by
your your parents if uh you know during
their lifetime so that would change
um and you know there's a lot of people
that would be hurt by that
so this now goes into debate it goes
into the congress you're going to see
conservative democrats that are against
some of these policies you'll see
liberal republicans endorse some of
these policies
but it's a very interesting
philosophical shift in the white house
uh it is away from the notion that if
you cut taxes and cut
regulation uh the benefits of that will
eventually trickle down
to the middle income and lower income
people in the united states
biden is calling foul on that principle
and saying
it hasn't and we need to do something
about it
it'll definitely be interesting to see
where where the debate goes and where it
lands
john busse associate editor of the wall
street journal and fox news contributor
thanks a lot for your time my pleasure
from the fox news podcasts network i'm
ben dominic publisher of the federalists
and i'm inviting you to join a new
conversation with the smartest thinkers
out there
about the country and where we're going
subscribe to the ben dominic podcast
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcast.com
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
[Music]
walker smallwood's dream of becoming a
professional baseball player was cut
short by a rare bone cancer in his leg
he was diagnosed in 2018 when he was
just 15 years old
since then he's had numerous surgeries
and chemotherapy
as well as other treatments in hospital
stays but recently walker who is now a
high school senior
returned to the mound for the first time
since starting his fight against cancer
and what happened was like a movie plot
i guess it just feels like i'm at home
it's what i love to do he and his team
and his coaches
figured he'd last for maybe a few
innings my doctor kind of told me that
it probably would never happen so yeah
for a while i never thought i'd play
again
going out on the mound just kind of take
a look around and be like wow i'm
actually here
like i never really thought that would
happen so just seeing the fans and
seeing my teammates around me it's a
pretty awesome experience he ended up
throwing a no-hitter
19 strikeouts in seven innings coming
off the mound i definitely had tears in
my eyes and
when i saw my parents i was just
i didn't even know what to say walker's
cancer is now in remission
but he still goes for checkups every few
months
tanya j powers fox news
[Music]
it's time for your fox news commentary
giano caldwell
what's on your mind screaming crying
yells of thanking god
were all heard all over the world last
tuesday
after the jury found former minneapolis
police officer derek show
guilty on all accounts in the death of
george floyd
i too felt at peace here in the verdict
and posted a message on instagram
thank god justice in the derek chauvin
case was served
guilty on all charges even though i'm
pro-police and a black conservative who
understands the overwhelming majority of
police officers
do their job honorably i also know
police must be held
to account when they violate their oath
and figure
most conservatives feel the same way
never once did i think this would be a
controversial take
on what happened when george floyd was
killed
there wasn't a single person i knew who
said he deserved to die
but now i was shocked to discover that
some conservatives
vehemently disagreed with the outcome of
the trial
part of this backlash stems from the
progressives push to defund
or even abolish the police in the wake
of the floyd tragedy
polls show that all americans including
black americans
overwhelmingly support policing in their
neighborhoods
and 20 percent of blacks actually want
to see more police presence near their
homes
the left's baseless claims that all the
cops are racist
also obstruct any nuanced discussion on
the issue
rather than encouraging real unnecessary
police reform it has led to resistance
to any reform at all
and reform does need to happen the fear
that some african americans feel during
police interactions is real
even as a staunch pro police
conservative i also feel nervous even
anxious when
being stopped by the police this
shouldn't be the case for any
law-abiding citizen
for years the national organization and
black law enforcement executives have
been trying to change that by advocating
for race
sensitivity training the increased
recruitment of african-american officers
and national use of force guidelines
this is the kind of reform we need
senator tim scott the only black
republican in the senate made it clear
that he too supports sjogren's guilty
verdict as well as meaningful change
we know there is more work to be done to
ensure the bad apples do not define all
officers the vast majority of whom put
on the uniform each day
with integrity and servant's heart he
said in a statement
we must all come together to help repair
the tenuous relationship
between law enforcement and black and
minority americans
senator scott is again working on police
reform after democrats shut down such
efforts last year
in order to inflame racial divisions so
that they could win political races
i hope and pray that democrats don't
once again obstruct the senator's
important push for police reform
this shouldn't be a partisan issue
indeed to make a real difference
both priorities must put aside politics
and come to the table
and democrats need to stop assuming
absurdly
and erroneously that all law enforcement
is racist
until we can have an honest dialogue
with each other the system will remain
broken
that's not a country any of us should
want this is gianno caldwell fox news
political analyst
and host of the podcast out loud with
gianno caldwell
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news
go to foxnews.com
fox nation presents podcasts women of
the bible speak
i'm shannon breem host of fox news at
night and author of the new book
women of the bible speak the wisdom of
16 women and their lessons for
today subscribe now on apple podcast
spotify foxnewspodcast.com or wherever
you download your podcasts
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes